Speaker 1: The next front in the culture war
against education is Florida's new battle
against math textbooks. David, what
the hell are you talking about?
Has Florida gone crazy? Yeah. Yeah, but that's
not new. The new situation in Florida is that the
Florida Department of Education announced going
into the weekend that they are now rejecting
more than 50 math textbooks, not history,
that they don't like how it's being taught,
not human geography or social studies.
They're rejecting more than 50 math textbooks,
citing references to critical race theory among
reasons for rejecting these books. The department
has rejected 54 out of one hundred and thirty two
textbook submissions because they don't adhere
to the new standards in Florida or because
they contain so-called prohibited topics.
This is the reasons they are saying, Ah,
the books have critical race theory in them.
They include Common Core. They include unsolicited
admissions of social, emotional learning
in mathematics. Now asked for examples. I've been
unable to find even a single one, and this is the
new fight. They're saying math is being taught
with a basis in Marxism. They're saying math is
attempted to be taught with a basis in critical
race theory. And you may remember that Florida
banned these words, even though the language being
used is so stupid. Florida banned the teaching of
critical race theory in schools in June. Now,
of course, critical race theory wasn't being
taught in schools, but what they will say when
pressed. And they're going to say the same thing
with the math books you say. Well, but where was
critical race theory a subject? They'll say, No,
no, David, it's much more pernicious than that. I
go right into my Alex Jones voice. It's much more
pernicious than that. It's that they use critical
race theory as a framework to teach history. It's
not that it's a subject, and similarly, they're
using it to teach math. I, you know, I remember
when I was in school, you always had these
funny math examples. Calvin Butterball
eats six apples. You remember these? I don't
know what the critical race theory version is.
Cohen has four oranges. Is Juan a dangerous,
illegal? I mean, like, I don't even understand
what what is it that they want to see in these
books? And of course, they're offended. They're
outraged. This can't be. This is terrible
for our children. And when we say, well,
can you give an example of the critical race
theory in the math books? They don't, they don't
say and conveniently, and I don't want to pretend
that this is just about money. But textbooks are
a big, big industry. It just so happens that
when you look at the white listed textbooks,
there is a bunch of some of them are actually
Florida textbooks that I don't I don't. We
want to look into it more. But there's always
potentially some kind of cronyism there. Hey,
we'll make sure that your textbook is the one that
gets purchased here. This is the new fight. And
what really pains me about this is that this
works. Look at Virginia. Look at the Virginia
gubernatorial election that we had where Glenn
Youngkin ran on banning critical race theory
from Virginia schools, and it convinced people
and many people voted for him for that reason.
There's no critical race theory being
taught in Virginia. There wasn't any.
Now, sure, a young man's opponent,
Terry McAuliffe, made some mistakes
like, you know, running against Trump when Trump
wasn't a candidate and young and didn't endorse,
didn't embrace Trump. That was a big mistake
from Democrats. But when you interviewed voters,
they said, Oh yeah, no, I'm concerned about
what's going on in education critical race
theory. But a lot of that, they fell for it
and they voted for young. And so this stuff
works. And with DeSantis up for reelection as
governor in 2020 to this year, and with DeSantis
the number one challenger to Donald Trump in
polling for the 2024 Republican nomination,
there is no doubt that he knows this stuff works
and they're going to keep pushing it. Let me know
your thoughts. You can find me on Twitter at De
Packman also tomorrow. Tomorrow. It's already.
It's already almost come and gone. The next
David Pakman show viewers Town Hall is tomorrow,
Tuesday, April 19th at 6:00 p.m. Eastern. It'll be
streaming live on the Pacman Live YouTube channel.
I hope to see you there. The David Pakman Show
is a viewer and listener supported program,
we depend on you to do what we do every single
weekday produce a one hour show and a 15 minute
extra show for our members, and you can
sign up and support our work. Join Packman
dot com. I would love to see
you join the ranks of membership